You need to pick your
investors very carefully,
probably as carefully that you want
to pick your your co-founders.
Because while you can
part from a co-founder,
it's very hard to part form an investor.
He have money.
He put money in your company and
the money's gone, and what now?
It will be very hard to buy him out.
So, you need to make
sure that you're taking
money from someone you can work with and
you can learn form and
can bring actual value
to you in your company.
Because if you're working with someone
who just can't bring you money.
There's this horrific expression,
friends, fools and family.
And what is fools?
You're taking money from a fool.
It's so bad.
It's getting the entrepreneur
condescending, yeah,
I'll take money from that fool.
Or you're taking money from
someone who can't help you.
It's horrible and
it makes entrepreneur seems stupid.
So, never take money from a fool.
And try not to take
money from family also.
And not from friends.
I hate that expression,
family, friends, it's horrific.
But choosing the right investor
can make or break your company.
Because a bad investor that try
to micromanage the company and
try to micromanage you.
And demands explanations.
And wants to be involved in everything.
Can really make you miserable.
And if you're not experienced you don't
know how to put him in his place.
And it can make your life very,
very hard.
A good investor can make your company,
can help you do everything.
But a bad investor, and
there's more bad investors than good
investors, can really hurt you.
And there's not enough money in
the world to to make this worthwhile.